dans les décombres les pompiers
cherchent des survivants
la ville de soum il vient d'être
bombardé dans la nuit les avions russes
ont frappé ces maisons vingt-et-une
personnes ont péri dans ce déluge de feu
dont deux enfants soumis à l'est de kiev
figurait pourtant parmi les cinq villes
où un cessez-le-feu devait être instauré
ce matin pour faciliter l'évacuation des
civils
il y a eu un accord sur les couloirs
humanitaires mm est-ce que ça a
fonctionné ce qui t'as des chars russes
ont continué les lance-roquettes plus
les mines russes mais l'horizon même
1000 et la route qui devait importer de
la nourriture et des médicaments pour
les gens pour les enfants les landais
l'élite et à kharkiv cette école est en
feu après avoir été visé par une attaque
de l'armée russe
la deuxième ville du pays a de nouveau
été bombardées
découpez le béton s'accrocher à l'espoir
de retrouver des rescapés dans cet amas
de ruines les secours travaillent sans
relâche
sur mon visage bien que je sois un
militaire à la retraite ma femme a été
blessée par des éclats d'obus futur car
elle est maintenant à l'hôpital ce pass
lice
dans cet hôpital de kharkiv les blessés
affluent sans cesse depuis plusieurs
jours touché par des éclats d'obus ou de
roquette irina a survécu miraculeusement
nous étions cachés au sous sol dans un
garage lorsque le bombardement a frappé
j'ai été blessé à la nouveau
comme cette femme visage ensanglanté
les civils demeurent des cibles son
immeuble de nicolas yves a été éventré
par une frappe
cette ville portuaire au sud près de
dessin est à son tour pilonnée par
l'armée russe